i think it's real really disingenuous to
not talk about the fact that a lot of
people are selling things that they
cannot believe there was a human being
on stage yesterday who said we believe
that people watch television
so that they can watch our commercials
[Laughter]
and i pioneered online research
and i had all male bosses that were not
eq
i i came to them and i said let's
migrate research from offline to online
and their answer to me was it's not the
right time
and
because there was no one online at the
time and had i've listened to them
and waited and watched i would not be
where i am today and so everything that
you said
is so
true and so relevant and it had i not
have been on a panel with the chief
research officer of procter gamble and
asked him when is the right time for me
to come and talk to you about migrating
research to the internet and him saying
come to me next week
i would not have pioneered online
research and at that time it wasn't the
right time i had to make it the right
time
and get ahead of
it it
and make it
work and build the ecosystem
and and that was the first second and
third and so when you were talking about
how behind this industry is and of
course in one of your
you know um
socials i saw you challenging the whole
industry here
and what did you tell them well i'm not
sure i'm challenging the whole week so
i'm not sure what the clip is well i
think you told them they're lying
yeah i mean i i do think i do think my
biggest challenge
it's i do think the biggest challenge i
have with the industry which i adore i
mean the makeup of the people this
industry is phenomenal like one of the
reasons i love coming is so many
wonderful people but
i think it's real really disingenuous to
not
talk about the fact that a lot of people
are selling things that they cannot
believe there was a human being on stage
yesterday who said
we believe that people watch television
so that they can watch our commercials
capture this
not 1992 not 1982 not 1972 not 1962 not
1952 there was never a time ever that
people decided i'm going to watch leave
it to bieber just so i can catch the
coca-cola commercial there was probably
and and i've done a lot of homework this
there was a time where the commercial
wasn't was a slight enjoyment part
you were curious it did have a different
culture the remote control had been
invented
there was a lot more creative fire
in the ad world in the 50s and 60s
not because of anything but because
people actually saw the commercials thus
inspired
highly creative people to want to make
them
and so yes i i do think that i mean
there's people selling media
here that is not transparent media
i mean the the
sh for all the wonderfulness that is
outside one thing that is not outside in
any shape or form ever at can is common
sense
there is no version of common sense
otherwise nothing that is being said
would be said
and i think that the industry is within
itself
i don't think we can go and interview
the eight billion people on earth and
ask them to recall four commercials that
they could today
uh there is no network television
consumption going on it's all gone to
streaming
uh and you know yes i i really struggle
with that i i think it's
incredibly challenging for me to wrap my
head around the concept of selling
something that in my soul i don't
believe in and i think that happens a
lot in our industry
well i i think you know when we think
about also and i talked about this the
other day you know omnimedia which is
multimedia but we don't live in a linear
world we live in an omnipresence world
where you're where consumers own
what they want what they watch when they
watch it and how they want to watch it
which is you know consuming all forms of
media in real time at the same time
you know in a whole
different fashion
comma
that is all about the content we
actually want to watch correct
none of that
is the things that people make to
interrupt those people and try to sell
them correct when people say gary you're
wrong about tv people watch sports i'm
like people watch sports
that's very different than people
watching the commercials during a
sporting event
and so and meanwhile comma i think this
in a you know this is a very global talk
but the super bowl ad in america is the
best ad in the world you get 60 to 100
million people actually consuming it and
wanting to consume it you know people
always like well there's big events like
the oscars and the olympics and the
super bowl i'm like no no those are big
events but the variable difference
between the super bowl commercial
and the oscar commercial there's not one
conversation about the oscar commercial
by normal people the ad world wants to
make it happen
it'll get covered and so yeah i i really
struggle with these variables yeah it's
also why by the way the last measure pre
us adding gem the gender equality
measure was likability we added
likability
uh
over 20 something years ago when social
came about because ads that people
choose to watch they watch over and over
and over again which is why we added
likability and adding the emotive side
the emotion if it pulls your heart
strings so i want to get to web three
okay for a minute because you have a
tremendous amount of people here and a
lot of women and you are doing so much
for women in web 3. and one of the
things that we are trying to do is
upskill educate awareness we just
released a great study um with ewg on
women in web3 which is phenomenal so
many great results so i hope you consume
it and post it and share it
and it's it's you know everything that
you are doing to bring women into web
three and to drive change and to embrace
and endorse tell us why that's so
important to you um bringing so much
more women into web3
because education matters you know i
love talking about you know a lot of
parents get mad at me because i put a
lot of tick tock content of like college
might not be the answer and i say i do
say it a little bit different than that
uh and so i get tons of feedback from
parents but for the first seven years of
that content it was all [ __ ] you gary
get out of my kid's scream you're
[ __ ] up my child's life in the last
three years it's been like you've really
helped my family like we've actually had
different conversations with our kids
and things are happening and it really
is again fun to be misunderstood up
front and then understood differently
later
so i've always struggled with the way
education is packaged and sold in the
world but the most important thing in
the world is education the reason i
answered your question with education
over the last 15 years as my life has
progressed
as as i've started to get more notoriety
and more awareness and more eyeballs
somewhere seven or eight years ago i
started listening to things like this
and many other things that we all
consume and i would start hearing things
from individuals of like hey the leaders
need to do something about this the
leaders need to do something about this
it's important that the pioneers of
something bring everyone along and i
remember like you know i mean when
you're a kid and going through it it's
not even on your radar you're not a
leader you start getting a little bit
momentum you're sitting in the middle
and you start getting kind of almost
curious and i remember like seven or
eight years ago
being pretty confident because the math
was clear and i know my chemicals and my
feelings i'm like oh okay like one day
i'm going to be in a position where
there's gonna be a lot of people
listening and i need to be very
thoughtful about what i talk about and
how i talk about it and what i do and
you know i think for there's some people
in here
that faces i know for a long time and um
you know the content evolves with the
context of your own life the market the
things that you're passionate about
and
and so when the web 3 thing happened
you know web one i was a child trying to
help my dad's liquor store web 2
i was in the middle of my life where i
had already built my dad's business for
him and had very little economics and
had probably a lot of emotions about
that that like i built this humongous
business but i never got paid more than
70 or 80k a year and so family
businesses are very very challenging and
so when web 2 came i saw it as my
opportunity i understood something was
happening and that obviously built the
foundation of what most people know
about me today
web 3 when it came
it came as i'm in a different place in
my career and i had options and
opportunities to do something and so i
remember very quickly saying okay
this is different this is an opportunity
for me i'm going to lead here
because i already have a big platform
i'm going to do what i've always done so
i'm going to be historically correct i'm
going to put in the work i'm going to
execute i'm going to communicate i'm
going to make content
but i need to be thoughtful of who and
how and what i do here and so
all the education combos with you and
others and just the way i've lived my
life made me realize i have a chance to
really help here
first and foremost because this is
something i'm incredibly proud of i was
uncomfortably focused on my community
i educated the [ __ ]
out of people that followed me and every
single hour not every day i get an email
from people who are like you changed my
life because i got involved
so early and this happened and that
happened and it just it's incredible not
only be friends like
i minted
world of women meant it out because of
me i minted it and went right into my
discord and twitter and said buy this
right and
mumbot or
women and weapons and you know i just
knew
what i was watching from january to may
in 20 which was
you know
highly curious web 3 blockchain
individuals were were the most active
it skewed the way a lot of early
technology skewed
i went first at my community which is
quite diverse by nature so that
immediately started to
uh
change the way but then when i was
watching the projects themselves
i saw an opportunity and i put in a lot
of work i put in the work i would search
twitter and search discord and followed
and followed and waited for things that
were coming from black artists female
artists it was being educated and being
thoughtful that when you have a platform
you can have a variable difference on
the world by the way all of us can do
that because that's what i was feeling
the whole way even when i had 13
followers or 24 you're still influencing
when you're a parent you're influencing
one two three people very heavily right
and so
it was just it was exciting for me and
to be very honest it's intoxicating i'm
excited to spend the next 50 years of my
life to do things that are selfishly
fulfilling for me whether they're
financially or creativity or
and excuse me while i'm doing that being
very thoughtful about the selfless part
of that as well and being thoughtful
about the things that i care about and
diversity inclusion is something i care
about um there's many things i care
about most of all what i care about
is trying to have a conversation around
self-esteem
i say it in a million different slang
terms and i hide it in my content to
trick people into my world so that i can
then reframe
success which is for me
so based on being content
and happy with what you've got
eliminating envy
completely tuning out the judgment of
others who have no context on your
actual truth and trying to find a way to
live within the means of your financial
reality
uh so that you don't put yourself in a
vulnerable spot to have to not do
something you like and so everyone's got
different things they care about and so
um that's what i spent my time on
so i have something to say so i mean
that was that was like
as i say like
a motherly hug but it really was a
sisterly hug because i was gonna cry
because i was feeling this moment of
such pride because
i got to meet gary's family at vcon and
um
honestly gary speaks such truth because
you are so famous it's true you have so
many friends
but they're such real friends
you at vidcon you know your proudest
moment was you were surrounded by your
breasts your best friends all came
i walked in this auditorium i don't know
where we were
where it was and this big auditorium and
all this stuff
minnesota vikings stadium
and there was all these security
people there and i walk in and
of course talk to the security people to
say where am i and you're in this big
stadium
and i think security and he said the
security people said you know
everyone that comes through this door
are the nicest people
you know because they're used to all
these celebrity people and concerts and
everything they said you all are so
nice and i said yeah because all seventy
thousand people or ever many people were
there are all gary vee friends
it's true garyvee we were all your
friends and even people you don't know
are part of your culture
you know because you really
inspire us all
to be
good and kind and in a garyvee likeness
and i don't i know you know
you know even
this to someone the other day
like this place was designed by women
for women and even all of you guys in
here you you close the
seats you put the seats up the toilet
down
and you take the napkins and put them in
the trash can we did it
and you're so respectful and you're so
kind
and you know inclusive
and it's a culture and that's the gary v
way
i was so proud of your mom because you
are
mommy and so yummy and like i just
so nice and that whole stadium where
garyvee
like and that is who you are and i just
i'm so proud of you and i'm so inspired
and i'm so grateful and for all of us
women to be so supportive and all of you
women i keep saying you've got to get in
first we got to stay in
gary is always yes i text him and he
right away writes us back and is helping
all of us get in get in early educate
upload supportive there's no better
friend to help us be first be second be
third and that is the truth because we
are going to write the rules of web
three so it doesn't become the boys club
it becomes an inclusive safe space right
okay and then the other thing you know i
talked about you know paris hilton was
in here you know so vulnerable and
sharing you know her inner truth and i'd
ask her that question and we talked
about it you know how she went from you
know playing those parts of you know
being the dumb blonde and owning her
real truth of herself and she had said
to me it's because you know she really
realized that she wasn't happy playing
that part that was a part she played and
then she found her real self and it's
really who you are and you said that you
are always you
talk about that
being always you is extremely hard
you know
a lot of people
let's talk about this business i've been
in it for 13 years
13 years later
what's amazing about truth is it finds
its way sometimes it's a day sometimes
it's a century but truth is a funny game
it finds its way and
for when you're when you're when you're
obsessed with the notion of not
compromising who you are
and being comfortable with your own skin
it comes with an extraordinary amount of
judgment
i am
wildly for the people that know me best
wildly soft-skilled oriented
deeply based on kindness and empathy and
compassion however
as a communicator in most settings a
podcast on stage i'm incredibly over the
top
highly aggressive
sports wrestling it's who i am i'm i'm
incredibly comfortable in my high energy
in in my tenacity in my ambition in in
my deep competitiveness i it's who i am
the problem is when you're that guy
and this is 13 years ago definitely
today when you're that guy there's an
incredible amount of judgment when one
know doesn't know any more about you
this this industry the wine business
whether it's like it it follows me
everywhere and it's it takes a lot to
especially when you're proud of how you
treat people and who you are
to to get just a headline reading one
clip one curse word out of your mouth he
he's this he when hustle porn got thrown
at me that was devastating one person
wrote one medium article with 50
falsities in it but people just ran with
it because unfortunately the world has
pain
which i'm incredibly empathetic to
there's not a single time i'm faced with
hate that i'm not compassionate to why
it's happening not one time i understand
why it's happening it still doesn't
taste good when you're on the receiving
end of it
and we're so quick to judge we've become
incredibly good at pointing fingers and
we're really really scared to use our
thumbs
the accountability has gone completely
out of the window
you know the leaders of the world have
no civility towards each other thus
we've now started to do that and and
then on top of everything else i'm a
really interesting character i
understand communication so well
that if i'm trying to create change i
know that there's certain patterns of
the chess move that i have to do to get
people to buy in to then later do the
work that i need to do to get there
which is in triple challenging because
you you know you're
connecting with certain individuals on
one part of your life
you know that you're putting in the work
to try to reframe the conversation for
them in a different way
but you know that the way you're getting
them in is being judged by everybody
who's virtue signaling you judging you
and and it's challenging
we and and i always talk i like talking
about this because i always want to
remind people no look look how in this
room everyone looks different and
today's age
which i find incredibly appropriate
because for the last eight trillion
years it was the reverse in today's age
for the micro second
the judgment towards a white male with
no context is extremely high
i find that appropriate is a it's a
macro counter reaction to centuries work
however on an individual basis
one human being
their mother might have been an
alcoholic they might have had a family
that had money and lost it all and like
like
this concept
that you know anything about i mean
think for a second right now all of us
about
the people in your direct family
that don't know everything about you
i'm talking about your mother and your
siblings that don't know actually every
single thing
how the [ __ ] do we know anything about
each other in this room
and so for me it's
i'm willing to be judged
because i know what i'm doing with the
attention
and i'm willing to have scrutiny up
front
to
have the accolades later
this town 13 years ago when we were
talking about the companies that we were
talking about they [ __ ] on them they now
completely control this town
right and so you know being historically
correct is incredibly gratifying it
takes incredible strength internally to
deal with the short-term judgment
and i'm incredibly proud of the stories
and the things that i'm doing and i'm
capable and i take down this
responsibility at a very high level i am
capable of reaching
many
many many many people
that most people that have the same
values that i have and want the world to
look the way everybody in this room
wants to look have no capability of
getting to
i do that
at the judgment of the people that i see
the world the same with for so that i
can later accomplish what we want to
have happen and i
it's probably the thing i'm most proud
of in the world and and i talk about it
out loud because there's others who have
that ability but they can't deal with
the short-term judgment of their
contemporaries or the people they
respect
thus unable to accomplish
what we're actually trying to accomplish
it is very hard to change the world
through judgment
and and for me it's not
how i see it i want to achieve it
through compassion to every single
variable of how one gets there and then
once that trust is built have thoughtful
conversations that may move the ball
down the field
[Applause]
[Music]
you